Hello? Oh...
"Flashing lights, black and white"...
Oh, what is this?
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome to Exposure.
Oh hello... *static noise in background*
OHH, okay. Oh, this is me!
OHH!
Oh, this is the weirdest thing!
Ok, interact.
Sorry. Oh. [Reads text on paper]
Ok, I know how this goes!
I should not open that door! and it's going to kill me!
I should not open that door, and it's going to kill me!
Thats how this goes, I know this!
I know this for a fact, I know this very well.
Ok, well, let's get to it...
Glad this is a Blair-Witch-Style documentary of everything that's gone horrible in my life...
Oh my God, oh my God!
I'm sorry if this is incredibly disorienting, but I kinda like it.
I kinda love it!
[faint, scratchy background noise]
Hello? Hi!
Oh, why is it so dark in my goddamn apartment?
Why do I have a fish-eye lens?
What is this, is a work lamp? Is that all I have?
Oh, hello...!
*nervously*
Hi... ok...
Alright then... Oh it's dark in here...
Ok...Oh man, I do not like this.
Oh hello! Oh a key! Great!
*static sounds*
OHH KAY.
[door slamming]
[with cadence] Fucking, what the fuck was THAAT?
Oh okay...!
Alright!
There's a mirror mis- oh god, not going in there!
Holy fucking shit.
What is you?
It's a bathroom, ah fuck!
Everything looks terrifying in the dark!
Ehh...
Oh god, this game is giving me the heebie-jeebies.
Oh incredibly- I'm not going in there yet!
There's a mirror missing?
Was there a mirror there before?
Oh that's getting- that's getting really...
That gets really fuzzy when I look at that, or maybe it's always that way.
Ok, here we go..
Hi! Oh boy this looks bad.
Oh, hey, hidy-hidy-hidy-ho!
Oh why the fuck is this here?
Ok, you know what? Ok, alright. I know what to do.
Hi-Ya! *whack*
Why? *whack* Why would I do tha- Why would I-
[ominous ambience]
Why would I do that? I'm in a building in New York!
They're probably old, it would probably collapse the son of a bitch!
Yeah, yeah "not possible"
*nervous laughter*
Definitely not possible *nervous laugh*
oOoh, oh boy
Why do I have to go back? Why do I keep going--
[cheery musical chime]
Hi, ok, I'm a brave boy, I'll press forward... [chime plays again]
Oh god, oh god, oh god, I don't like this...
UHHHH I don't like it, I don't like it!
Ok nope, not doing that, ok alright ok bye-bye, oh I--
It's the "Bye-Bye Man"
What is this?
Wait a minute that's not right..
Why is there like an outline of a mirror there?
The fuck is that sound?
Oh this is some found-footage-craziness
Alright fine!
I'm gonna go into the darkness, and I'm not gonna turn around!
Just gonna press on..
Here we go...
Aaauggh!
ooooh-AHHHH
*scary music in background*
Ok...
O...K...
I-I-I don't know what I'm looking for..
Oh fuckin- what the fucking fuck?
What is this? What is this?!
What am I looking at?
*screams*
*quiet scream*
Oh god, can't tell where I am...
Oh god, what's that?
There's something there- ok, alright
Oh no. I gotta feel my way around the walls...
*screaming*
I hate this!
OH, I HATE THIS!
Whoa, what the fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?!
Oh ok, I thought it was- oh-
It's a door!
Oh, ok, there's a door in here! I found one!
*nervously* okay?
Hello? Hi—Oh goddamnit...
Fucking hell
Well you kinda did to come back here!
For whatever fuckin reason..
Ok, just gonna... carry on...
Do I grab the sledgehammer or just keep going I guess?
Just keep going I guess..
Keep going I guess.. ah boy..
Oh boy
Ok
Ok...
*piercing noise,* YEEH YEEH YEEH  YEEH YEEH YEEH  YEEH YEEH YEEH!
The fucking fuck?!
What the fuck is that?
*sound intensifies*
Ok, alright then!
"The gate is open now," How do you know?
What is the gate to? Is it a gate to Hell?!
A gate to Heaven?
Oh there's a lot of noise happening..
*mechanical rustling noises*
I don't like this!
*rustling intensifies*
(Yelling)CHH-I don't like that!
*rustling intensifies more*
Oh fucking fuck, where am I?
What?
Okay...!
Ok-- AH, FUCKING, WHAT THE FUCK?!
Hi, how are you?!.... GO FUCK YOURSELF!
What do you got there? A camera? So do I!.. FUCK YOU
You want some of this? Huh? Bitch!
Fuck off!
Oh god.
Oh god, oh god, OKAY, I'm going, I'm gone, I'm gone baby, I'm GONE.
Okay there's the gate...
The gate is open now!
Ok, here we go! I guess. Alright.
Well...
eey yee yee yee ye YEE
Oh, well shit!
Ah...ok!
Well I guess I just sit here and wait calmly.
...For my death to arrive.
Oh- hey, hello! Hi!
I see you there!
Oh, you're comin'.
Wait- oh no!
You only walk when I do!
Oh, oh what the fuck?!
Oh, what the Hell?
What the Hell?
What the- oh, gee
Hi!
*loud mechanical noises*
Can't move!
....kay...
*camera flashing sounds*
Woah-kay...
*ambiance fades out*
Oh! That's the end!
Oh great!
Greeeat!
Wonderful!
Oh boy!
I feel horrible!
I feel uncomfortable.
I feel like I've been horrifically violated!
So...
I think that's the end?
Yup, seems like it.
So that was Exposure! Holy shit,
that was fucking terrifying!
I had no idea what was happening!
And it did a lot with very little.
Like the, uhh,
The VHS recording aspect of it made it
made like... the flaws of the..
the low graphics like, not seem apparent.. it was just...
Man, that was fucking terrifying.
I don't know what it means, I have NO idea what it means...
But you guys can interpret it for what you will, so...
Wow.
If you wanna try this game out, I'll put a link in the description below
and to the developer: You got a knack for this stuff buddy, you got a knack.
You got a good knack for it
so thank you everybody so much for watching, let me know what you thought of this down in the comments below
and as always, I will see you in the next video
bye-bye!
*horror outro plays*